So
I woke up this morning, I plan my morning
and we really planned the entire production
day around Washington as
much as the Robert Mueller testimony before
Congress as possible so that we could talk
about it today, which I'm going to do right
now rather than on tomorrow's show.
And I thought as I got on my computer at 8:25
AM this morning to pull up the stream, I should
see if Donald Trump has been tweeting because
he's been panicking for days.
Yesterday we covered Donald Trump saying that
Robert Mueller shouldn't even be allowed to
testify.
I should look at whether Donald Trump has
sent any tweets.
I pull up Donald Trump's Twitter account and
he sent 10 tweets in the hours and even minutes
before Robert Mueller's testimony starting
last night, winding up even more this morning.
This is a guy who's panicked.
This is the president.
It's important not to lose our sense of scope.
This is the president devolving into a childish,
an income poop.
And I use the term Nincompoop by its deck
dictionary definition, not as an ad Hominem,
uh, because of congressional testimony by
a former special prosecutor.
And you know what?
Unfortunately, in a sense, fortunately for
Trump Mueller's testimony, at least the first
several hours that have taken place as of
right now, have not been particularly damaging
to Donald Trump.
But we'll get to that.
Let's look at Donald Trump's tweets to begin
with starting last night.
Quote.
So Robert Mueller has now asked for his long
time, never Trump or lawyer to sit beside
him and help with answers.
What's this all about?
His lawyer represented the basement server
guy who got off free in the Crooked Hillary
case.
This should not be allowed.
Rigged witch hunt continuing.
So Democrats and others can illegally fabricate
a crime, try pinning it on a very innocent
president.
And when he fights back against this illegal
and treasonous attack on our country, they
call it obstruction wrong.
Why didn't Robert Mueller investigate the
investigator's continuing quote?
It was never agreed that Robert Mueller could
use one of his many Democrat, never Trump
or lawyers to sit next to him and help him
with his answers.
This was specifically not agreed to and I
would never have agreed to it.
Of course, it's not up to Trump the greatest
witch hunt in UFC history by far.
Why didn't Robert Mueller and his band of
18 angry democrats spend any time investigating
crooked Hillary Clinton Lyon and leaking James
Komi Lisa Page and her psycho lover, Peter
s, Andy, the beautiful or family fusion gps
and how many more and many more including
himself and Andrew w this is the president
tweeting.
Okay.
Continuing.
So why didn't the hide, why didn't the highly
conflicted Robert Mueller investigate how
and why Crooked Hillary Clinton deleted and
acid washed 33,000 emails out immediately
after getting a subpoena from the United States
Congress.
She must have great lawyers, no collusion,
no obstruction, keep America great.
Quick continuing.
This is still Trump on Twitter this morning.
It has been reported that Robert Mueller is
saying that he did not apply and interview
for the job of FBI Director and get turned
down the day before he was wrongfully appointed.
Special counsel.
Good luck even following this stuff.
Hope he doesn't say that under oath in that
we have numerous witnesses to the interview,
including the vice president of the United
States, Donald Trump melting down in a completely
unprecedented way, which says a lot when we're
talking about Donald Trump who has melted
down on Twitter many times before.
But then in the end, and again, maybe something
will change in the later hours of the testimony
that's still going on as we're filming today.
The first many hours have not been particularly
damaging to Trump, although there were many
damaging things said or confirmed by Robert
Mueller.
And Mueller is looking confused and not really
with it.
I have to say what I was looking for going
into the hearings today included, do Republicans
go after Mueller in d, uh, personally, despite
him having credentials that should appeal
to the right.
I mean, we're talking about military, a lifelong
Republican, a life of public service.
Do they try to assail his character?
And they did to some degree, what new information
comes out and hint, the answer is none.
Robert Mueller stating in his opening statement,
listen, we've charged 30 defendants.
We've had seven convictions or guilty pleas,
but basically the report is my statement and
I will be limiting myself to what is in the
report pointing out.
Importantly, his report nor his investigation
addressed collusion.
They looked at conspiracy, but collusion is
not something on which they reached a conclusion
because he didn't look at that period.
And that's an important thing.
But Moeller by and large looking confused,
uh, unable to hear questions cut persistently.
I mean, regularly.
And I don't think it's a strategy of trying
to kill time by asking for almost every question
to be repeated.
Mueller, uh, asking people about, um, uh,
who even some of the players in this thing
where at one point, I believe it was David
Salini from Rhode Island asked about Corey
Lewandowski, a very specific question.
And Molar said, can you just remind me who
Corey Lewandowski, uh, even is?
So, uh, I don't believe that this was strategy
by molar.
He genuinely seemed to be having trouble hearing,
having trouble recalling, uh, people's names
and their role in the investigation to some
degree, I guess to be expected because you're
dealing with hundreds and even thousands of
names here.
Um, but regularly saying, I'm going to pass
on that one that's outside my purview clamming
up.
But what's in the report is what I believe.
Even sometimes, uh, saying he can't comment
on something being reminded by a member of
Congress that it's in the report and then
saying, oh, well, in that case, my comment
is, what is in the report?
Uh, I don't know that this was particularly
successful for Democrats beyond one very specific
series of questions towards the beginning
where Mueller answering with his very short
yes knows it's in the report.
It's out of my purview.
Did confirm the obstructive nature of Donald
Trump's actions during the investigation,
including that the motivation to the extent
that the, uh, investigation came to a conclusion
on this, that Trump's motivation for his actions
in attempting to obstruct were specifically
meant to interfere with the investigation.
So overall, we'll, I'll go right back to watching
this after we're done filming today and we'll
have sort of a broader analysis tomorrow of
the impact.
It is not seeming to me that this testimony
is going to be a game changer and to that
extent for everybody who was waiting for something
explosive to come out of it.
As I said from the beginning, all we could
really expect from these hearings, uh, optimistically
was the proactive confirmation and publicizing
of what was already in the report.
Mother made clear the report is my statement.
I will not go beyond it.
There were lots of damaging things that Donald
Trump confirmed, but in a way that again was
sort of muddled stumbling around in the dark,
seemingly confused by Robert Mueller.
Um, also we, we learned that Louie Gohmert,
Congressman Louie Gohmert is completely off
the rails and really shouldn't be a member
of Congress.
If you saw bits of that testimony, you'll
probably know what I mean, we will have sort
of a full summary tomorrow, but I don't know
that it is necessarily going to move the needle.
And that is what gets me to this next topic,
which is really of utmost importance at this
point in time.